[Music]
one of the great secrets to to
maintaining a discipline in one's life
is that it has it has an incredible
meditative or Zen quality to it my
character in this film Frank is a little
bit obsessed with playing music and
creating music
it comes out in sort of an ugly way in
the scene on the porch at Tony Colette's
house where he just simply says but it's
it's kind of nicely underwritten he says
I don't want to sell music and what I
take from that is he's saying I don't
want to want to be the salesman of other
people's albums I want to be making my
album even if nobody buys it that's what
I should be doing and and I know that
feeling firsthand as it's somebody in
the performing arts when you know it's
an ugly business we've all kind of heard
stories about they're true about how
much rejection and how superficial the
business is it's very seldom merit-based
so for example I've done very well I'm
very grateful for all the wonderful good
fortune I've had but me and my wife and
all of our friends who have done well we
all have friends that we think are more
talented than we are and it didn't work
out the same way for them and so one of
them is teaching college now you know
they had their life took them on
different paths and so knowing that
people often ask me how can I get my kid
involved in in show business and the
same might be might be asked to Frank
you know how can how can we make it how
can our band make it as musicians and I
always say I would advise that you take
up woodworking because it's addictive
it's an addictive craft that is so
satisfying that doesn't require the
input of any corporate entities so quite
frequently in Los Angeles when I would
go to a big audition
for like a TV pilot or something that
like really would change my life it's
incredibly stressful you're just doing
your best for days to keep your cool you
go do the thing and it's invariably for
a roomful of bankers so it's a terrible
room usually with me I'm trying to get a
laugh and they're all like they all have
their abacuses out and I'm like well in
Maxim magazine he has a mustache that's
17 points and and you leave and it's
just inscrutable you're like I have no
idea how I did which is which has gives
you a lot of stress and a lot of agita
so I would go straight to my shop and
just start sanding a walnut table and
after just an hour of that I'd put on
some music and I would see the tangible
result of this work that I had done
that's the thing is there's no way to
describe the sensation there's magic in
it whether you're whether you're working
with glass or metals or food or knitting
or wood you're you're making something
better than it was it was a pile of
stuff and now it's a lasagna then you've
done that with with your magic powers
and so that sensibility that that Zen I
find so incredibly healthy again as a
human being with foibles when left to my
own devices I will happily especially
when I was younger I'd be like oh I
suddenly have the day off unexpectedly
let's go get drunk and go to the movies
and that's fun once in a while I don't
you know I don't disparage it but it
should be a special occasion when you
get to doing it with any regularity
that's when it becomes unhealthy and so
anything in this realm I I have found it
to be life-saving and the thing is it's
it's antithetical to what we're taught
about business and especially about show
business show business you're supposed
to hustle all the time you're supposed
to beat people's doors down and be
flashy and
selling yourself and I was never able to
do that stuff if people weren't gonna
give me jobs based on the merit of the
work I was doing I wasn't interested in
selling myself beyond that and so iti I
didn't do this because I was wise I did
this I tricked myself into this by
listening to the right teachers by going
away and working in my woodshop that
gave me a mellowed demeanor to the point
that I no longer cared as much about the
TV shows also related to this movie I
mean this is the theme for me of this
movie is if you are having dilemmas in
your life if you're experiencing loss or
there's any kind of trauma or tragedy
it's something we all have to deal with
at some point as long as you focus on
the love relationships in your life and
the health of them and that health could
mean screaming at each other and saying
I'm sick of you the way how you leave
the toothpaste cap off or whatever it is
that's that is healthy you're working it
out so you can live together and love
one another whether it's your mom or
your daughter or your your spouse or
your sibling if you focus and maintain
the health of those relationships
everything else is going to be okay you
may lose your job you may get another
job that doesn't matter jobs will come
and go but you want that love
relationship to always matter and in
this movie my character Frank learns
that if he if he makes the right
decision and focuses on his love
relationship his dream will always be
there his dream is playing music he
makes the right decision as a parent
everything works out in a satisfactory
way he doesn't become a rock star but
his dream continues and in my life by
chilling myself out in my woodshop
amazingly when I got my big break they
said oh we're this is a we love your
woodshop we're going to make him a
woodworker
somehow my woodworking my my antidote to
show business became part of my persona
and now I have a campaign doing
commercials for a glue company so if you
want to get in if you want to get on
stage learn how to use a chisel
[Music]